hello everyone and welcome to game
number seven of the 1970 Palma de
Majorca inter-zonal
tournament here Bobby Fischer faces with
the white pieces Milan Mutulu it Serbian
Grandmaster and in those days somewhere
from 1960 to 1970 okay bizarrely Grich
probably I'm pretty sure was the best
you go saw a grandmaster but then in
second place he definitely would have
either middle and medulla which or Boris
lava flow so definitely a strong run
master and he has faced Bobby Fischer
before when Fischer was a visiting
Belgrade in 1958 he played a training
match a four-game match against Milan
Mutulu which and only one game was saved
from that match from the four-game match
it was a game that no matter which one
I've never covered
I've actually covered that again but I
will put a link to it in the description
below so you can check it out if you
want and after that they have faced each
other a couple of times some of them
were blitz games some of the rule
classical time control but before this
game a Fisher Fisher the score is two to
one in Fischer's favor I believe and to
two games were also won by Fisher but
those Routledge games so a very
interesting matchup and it's also very
interesting that millon Mutulu which won
the Yugoslavs championship two times and
he competed there plenty of times for
the Olympiad so definitely definitely a
strong opponent and it's very
interesting I've never actually seen
this game before preparing it now for
the series it's extremely enjoyable and
Mutulu was really real plays an
excellent game so let's check it out the
Fisher of course opens with E for Mutulu
which goes for the Sicilian defense we
have c5 Knight f3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop to b5 Fischer goes for the
rasa-lila or the measurement Dean of
rosalie more variation we have g6 now
comes c3 Knight to f6 and Queen e2
Bishop to g7 now II five nights to d5
and now Queen to C for a very
interesting move by Fischer attacking
the c5 pawn and also attacking the
five night so what do you do here
in the game night to see seven was
played if you play something like Queen
to b6 would ideas of defending the c5
pawn and I okay if Queen captures here
then Queen can capture Bishop you could
simply play d4 and after d6 pawn
captures pawn captures and now Queen to
eat to check and black would lead her
face something like Bishop three six
followed by c-4 or he would have to move
King f8 and lose castling privileges but
here module which plays a very
interesting move a very nice pawn
sacrifice that really gains so much
activity here Mottola which played the
night the c7 Fisher accepts the
challenge he plays Bishop captures on c6
we have D captures on c6 and now Queen
captures on c5 so grabbing a pawn but it
will be very hard for him to justify
grabbing this pawn I'm at Ola which
immediately plays Queen to d3 winter d3
is a beautiful move as Fischer did play
c3 you can't develop with Knight to c3
you can't push the D pawn you cannot
castle the queen is slicing all the way
here so of course the Fischer grab the
point he wants to exchange Queens and
okay Mutulu she doesn't mind but first
he will play Bishop to a5 protecting his
Queen fishery accepts so Queen captures
we have Bishop captures and now the
bishop does the same job the Queen did
stifling White's development also
preventing Fisher from castling and
there's not all that much you can do
here you can try developing good night
to a3 that's not something you want to
do when you're you know down in
development so first King to d1 Fischer
is preparing to bring the rook into the
game a via rook to e1 we have nine three
six and now comes nice to e1 attacking
Mutulu which Bishop on d3 and now comes
Knight to f4 again
Mutulu which wants to get his night over
to d3 so then the night will be
preventing Fischer from from developing
any of his pieces Fischer captures
Knight captures on d3 we have Knight
captures on d3 and now comes f4 a very
interesting move you could play
something like King to see - sorry about
that King to see - getting the King out
of the way of giving back one point
but instead of this Fischer actually
protects at this point he offers the f4
pawn but also he offers nice to have to
check
so my tool which can actually win the
exchange here and the engine is really
going crazy for this but it's very
interesting and it's a very impressive
how much tool which doesn't want to grab
the exchange I'm a tool which wants to
keep playing this position actively and
she plays a Bishop to h6 playing
something like Knight captures to f4
okay you grab a pawn but then you allow
d4 that white really improved his
position he's bringing the rook into the
game all of his pieces can now develop
so all would be well here for white so
if you're if you're going for material
then you could have a play Knight to
have to check and grab the rook but he
decided to go Bishop to h6 so okay now
if we should go skiing to see - he
attacks the night and here we have
Knight captures on c1 again it would be
if you play something like Knight
captures and i-4 here then white would
you really get ahead because now after
d4 the knight is pinned the bishop on h6
is undefended here you would have to go
g5 and after g3 95 you could play h4 the
point is still pinned the bishop on h6
is undefended Fischer would have an
excellent game here so after King to c2
Knight captures on c1 we have rook to e2
first and now we have castles it would
be pretty much the same if you first
captured an f4 for example g3 after the
bishop moves only now capture but Mutulu
which still wants to keep all of his
pieces active so first queenside castle
bringing a rock into the game now we
have King captures on c1 and only now
Bishop captures on f4 g3 protecting the
h2 pawn we have brushed back to h6 and
now King to c2 as the d2 pawn is pinned
Fischer really wants to pull d4 and here
we have rook to d5 it's a it's a very
nice move when I first saw this position
I thought okay off-white of course wants
to play d4 naturally why not push c5 and
why well engine does engine doesn't mind
the c5 move he also doesn't mind rook to
d5 move so rook to d5 here we have
before by Fischer expanding on the Queen
side B 6 a 4 a 5 now and now B captures
on a 5 B captures an 85 and now rook to
e4
we have rook H to d8 and now comes the
d4 so okay only now does a Mutulu which
finally push c5 we have c5 King to d3
and now pawn captures and v4c captures
on d4 and now Bishop to g7 in some
variations if this rook moves then
Bishop will be able to capture here as
the pawn is pinned so first King to e3
and now bishop it back to h6 with check
Fischer has to go back King to d3 and
now Bishop back to g7 and here Fischer
doesn't want to repeat still Fischer
wants to push this all the way he plays
King to c4 we have f5 attacking
Fischer's rook and now although Fischer
can move his rook to h4 then Mutulu
which would attack at once again with g5
instead Knight to c3 is played and here
a very nice move by Mutulu which 6e
sucks now Fischer doesn't have the
opportunity to trade down because after
you capture here then your king is in
check
you have to move the King and then the D
captures only for grabs another rook and
then Mutulu which would simply be up up
a piece so after this a sex move rook to
h4 s played going after the h7 point but
now comes g5 attacking the rook rook
captures on h7 the d4 point is no longer
protected now comes Rock captors and d4
with check King to b5 a very dangerous
game by Fischer s he's really bringing
his king you know inside of blacks
territory
we have Bishop captures on e5 and now
comes roof to c1 we have looked the
before this comes with check again a
very nice move by Mutulu which forcing
Fisher's King all the way to the a file
while temporarily sacrificing a pawn
king characters on a5 and only now rook
to see for not allowing any discovered
checks from Fischer we have Knight to e2
offering a trade of rooks now first rook
the d5 check King moves the b6 and now
rook to c5 doubling up on the C file
Fischer has to trade down here we have
rook captures rook captures and now h4
Fischer is down
not down in material but he wants to
create a passport and the on the
kingside as well as he does have one on
the queenside we have looked to see to
attacking fishers night and here it's
very hard to do something with this
night as you can see the bishop is
controlling the night here the night
can't really go anywhere the only place
the night could go to his g1 but then
I'm a tool which can even afford the g4
and now this night really has nowhere to
go next move Bishop to c5 will trap the
night either with check but even if the
King moves the knight will be captured
so instead after this rook to c2 move
Fisher decides to sacrifice the piece
but as you'll see only temporarily H
capture son g5 would have rook captures
on e2 and now comes g6 rook to be - this
comes with check King to a6 and now
comes Luke the before look - before
attacking the a4 pawn trying to trick
Fischer to either defend the pawn with
King to a5 which loses the game after
key rook to g4 and now the g7 is no
threat as the bishop and the rook are
both regarding the g7 square or even
after work - before a 5 if that's played
also looked to g4 will prevent official
from doing anything with this g6 pawn
but Fischer doesn't allow Mutulu which
to trick him he pushes g7 immediately
doesn't mind the a for porn we have
Bishop captures rook captures and now
rook captures an a4 with check King -
before and now comes rook to d4 and if
you check out this position Mutulu which
is up to pawns but it's very hard for
him to take advantage of it okay Fischer
can't get anywhere near the pawns with
his King
but Mutulu which can't do anything with
his King either because Fischer's rook
cut it off from from entering the game
okay rook to e7 the Fischer goes after
the after the pawn we have rook to e4
defending but now King to c5 Fischer is
now able to improve the position of his
King King to d8 Mutulu which also
improves the position of his king rook
to a7 and now King to e8 King to d6 we
have King to f8 and now rook to b7 rook
to e3
we had rook to a7 and our roof to e1
rock to b7
rook to e4 and now rook back to a7 by
Fisher rook to e2 we worked to b7 and
now rook back to e3 attacking the g3
pawn rook back to a7 and now comes King
to g8 route back to b7 rook to e1 and
now rook to e7 again attacking the 7th
pawn and here there's really nothing to
do
Luke to e3 was played rook captures by
Fisher rope captures and jittery and
here after King to e5 the game they they
agreed to a draw so okay you're up upon
but there's no real way to take
advantage of it even if you defend it
rock here is coming and whatever you
play simply the rook will be grabbed and
the Kings will be will remain bare naked
so yeah after King to e5 a very nice
draw both of them played a very nice
game and even though Fischer really
really tried to do everything
Mutulu which really played a very nice
pawn sacrifice in the beginning of the
game after this after this Queen to see
497 captures captures and then Queen
characters in this Queen d3 first Queen
stifled Fisher's development then the
bishop stifled it and then the knight
from a 6 to f4 to d3 also helped out
with you know really not allowing
Fischer to develop any pieces but in the
end it was there's there's really no way
to tell I'm a tool which could have won
this game in some in some fashion but
definitely you know if you ask the
engine the engine really really likes
night to have to check here and picking
up the rook but Mutulu wanted to create
something beautiful you know perhaps
something something that will remain in
chess books for you know and and stand
the test of time but in the end he
managed to get only a draw but even this
draw you know stopped official from his
crazy winning streak so it's a draw from
Game one then five wins in a row then a
draw against Miller and mythology but
still an excellent game by Fischer and
an even greater game by Mel and Mutulu
which but you know still still a very
nice streak for Fischer without a single
loss so far so that
the game that's round number seven from
Palma de Majorca inter-zonal tournament
of 1970 I do hope you enjoyed it and
that you have enjoyed my coverage of the
series so far I would like to thank Kyle
care for your contribution to my channel
helping me out with the design of my
youtube cover and my twitter cover you
know all of you are welcome to check it
out I will also put a link to Kyle's
social media in description below so you
can check out some of his other work
it's also very nice so I do hope you
enjoy that as well so as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon with another game from the
Bobby Fischer series thank you all and
see you soon